[Music]
but did you watch the Deonte welder and
Tyson Fury fight well no I did it why
what kind of fight fan are you I'm a big
fight fan I heard you're a poser I think
we just proved it on Jake he needs you
here to get first what did we do it so
even our neighbor invited us over to go
watch it I was there I don't know what
you were doing
no but we did something we forgot what
we did though home because we were
[ __ ] tired doing your makeup I
watched some of the highlights though hi
who's working on jokes at Barba Barba
yeah is we're gonna scar beset haha
he's like one more comedies it okay I'll
watch the highlights and I know what's
going on highlights like him your makeup
god I'm good
you ain't a man yeah you missed your
fights alright so there was this fight
right with these two guys and one of
these guys walked out wearing a 40-pound
costume as a tribute to Black History
Month and that guy was the guy that lost
and blamed it on wearing the costume I
loved it I saw the costume the guy's
amazing
I love the costume was hilarious too
what does that do I don't know I think
to do with like doom if anything he
looks like he plays Diablo 2 like he's
like [ __ ] diablo 2 necro bad sir why
is that Black History Month [ __ ]
ballsy to come out like that and still
lose she's blaming it on the cops well
cuz it was so tired they said it wait
his legs down he came out to that thing
he's gonna win and then he gets his ass
beat and then afterwards he's like oh
the suit was 40 pounds so I have lays
there in the fight if he put it back on
and walk out of the reactor
so a 40-pound suit made his legs tired
by the time he did the walk out this is
the looks like an excuse to play a video
clip of him his legs a quarter a knee
and then I'm gonna play a clip and then
like in the same clip you're gonna see
them fight and all that stuff okay here
we go
tonight there's nothing on his feet
walking gonna flow sighs [ __ ] though
Bonnie that was a perfect cut by the way
from slow healthy how the fight started
yeah the ring looks really little it's
funny because like they do kind of look
like they have chicken legs but they're
[ __ ] massive like the ref is already
six feet tall yeah he's doing a [ __ ]
tribute to Skyrim dude come on that was
the right and then towards the end the
assistant trainer threw in the towel
which pissed him off even more exceeds
like we've talked about this for years
never ever ever ever ever throw in the
towel and then they did so he's mad at
that guy for that reason you threw in
the towel why though I mean like for its
safety well do was like bleeding on his
ear is he yeah so he's like I understand
why you did it
I get it was for my own good but lucky
yeah man
yeah but for him it's like we've talked
about it's the principle of the family
rather [ __ ] die in the ring
Davin you seen rocky go the distance
that's what you wanted to do that's how
Apollo Creed dad do you know what rock
you're throwing the towel I know that's
why we that's I don't want that happen
to him I don't want to Apollo him I was
like my rocky one but if you want about
Rocky four we can do that yeah it wasn't
for dude it was it was like two or three
right Rock make it boy like glimmering
are you ready Geo do you really want to
do this do you what do you think I have
any sort of dignity or pride to lose bro
okay on rocky fetch go baby I know I
don't know [ __ ] about Z for apologizing
rocky for in the beginning spoiler alert
oh yeah
you movie mr. t was walking for you okay
I like that one I know I know when he
gets revenge hot [ __ ] Drago's number
two for Drago yeah well star goes number
four yeah cuz Drago Drago kills Apollo
and then in number five rocky gets his
revenge in vitro joggled no that's that
before he gets his revenge abuse Tommy
gun that's five that's I don't make
knowledge by those who defy - fine I
don't know five I don't give a [ __ ]
about five five is terrible in fights in
the street he fights a guy bringing up
this protege and it the Protege turned
his back on him
well because rocky was a big I haven't
seen five and 15 years on them it's
probably like Karate Kid 3 no one saw it
Oh kid is like he does that motivational
talk with his kid that was rocky 7 Rocky
Balboa ear pierced no not that Rocky
Balboa come on about Tiger hair is about
how hard you can get ahead and keep
moving forward let's go let's go bro I
thought that was pre but it said I'll go
all in okay anyway back to this thing
which will as long as he's like wax on
wax off that's rocky jacket on jacket
off 9 min okay go on
okay dude me and Bart were probably the
only ones laughing watching that scene
and you know Karate Kid or kung foo kid
with Jaden Smith yeah and Jackie Chan's
like check it on anywhere like Oh God
jacket off jacket noisily that's really
good children yeah no we were like 22
I don't know we're like okay and I
wasn't even I was just generally under
30 okay
okay anyway so back to this story of
Deontay Wilder and tanks first Tyson
period so like I said Wilder was blaming
the forty pound costume right as to why
he lost etic but recently a clip of him
on drove Rogen's podcasts reveals that
he is being a sore loser okay of course
here we go
he's got a 45 pound vest on me as well
to it all by exercising so he's used to
yes to it buddy
well he got tired I thought he's gonna
talk way more [ __ ] to that I think
justice or months ago and said yeah
exactly
but what's crazy is he's supposed to be
the next coming of like Mike Tyson his
record is even better than Mike Tyson's
I think yes 42 wins and 41 knockouts or
so he doesn't look as good as Mike Tyson
when he fights them Mike Tyson blinking
lures the [ __ ] out of you people don't
remember though man that guy I remember
watching that [ __ ]
he would [ __ ] punch a guy and he's
the guy's gone you know that's this guy
except yes fight and then my thing just
looks like [ __ ] you don't see what
happened with his hands so fast what the
[ __ ] happened
my doesn't have you ever done knocked
out yeah yeah I did
so towards the end of his career didn't
do so Holyfield [ __ ] him up that's why
you bid is he oh yeah you didn't like
losing the post jail Mike Tyson you
really went to jail for that no no
obviously you got in trouble you went to
jail when he came out he was he wasn't
he's ever the same so a lot of the
people that when he beat when they beat
Mike Tyson they're saying they didn't
beat the real Mike Tyson like Lennox
Lewis Holyfield they're also attributed
to his coach who died yeah that was his
that was his father figure that was his
world and that was who was grounding him
his hypnotist yeah and when he was gone
that's when he went down watch Mike
Tyson Howard videos know their [ __ ]
boy your mind watch is what videos
highlight videos
[ __ ] crazy crazy I like to see
Jackson [ __ ] yeah when you're watching
the greatest ever done something it's
like that [ __ ] yeah my friend worked
with him and it it man
which one the when they did the fight
scene at the end it meant three or at
matzevot no the three she choreographed
that scene and he was saying that I was
like so in real life when Mike Tyson is
like trying to like do this stunt [ __ ]
right like is he still got his like
boxer waist he goes yeah man he's like
he's so naturally tight when he moves he
doesn't know how to open up for camera
and all this [ __ ] and I'm all like what
the [ __ ] and he goes even when he does
open he's like it's still good mm have
you seen him move I think it was on
Instagram or something a few months ago
like he was just like like fully quickly
and he was just [ __ ] around and I was
like [ __ ] [ __ ] him so good for
like almost being like in a Starbucks of
some [ __ ] like graybeard Tyson and he's
like showing somebody some said it's so
fast as I hope you're not still shrivel
what the [ __ ] yeah yeah and you did both
cuz you're like whoa you're nuts go high
got nuts just watching it yeah well the
thing yeah yeah he can dedicate your
life to killing hands you got the killer
hands man
that's how his interviews are dope when
they tell him like if he wants to get
into anything competitive he's like I
can't or also I'm just gonna want to
kill people
okay like he's gotten less crazier oh
yeah for sure he mailed out he's high
all the time now he sells weed down [ __ ]
he's got his own weed strands
transitions oh yeah he's - I believe you
yeah you did I'm not gonna better give
that with my Tyson facts I believe my
dad series can you please stop [ __ ] no i
100% agree you could tell me he trained
in iguana how to talk and I'd be like
that's awesome I know but he had didn't
stop [ __ ] with me he really acted
that I mean I know what's a really good
Mike Tyson highlight video his interview
so hoping yeah they're so good I love
you
say those things that he wanted these I
know that's why calm down he's also
surprisingly deep for a guy who we all
made fun of for talking the way he
talked yeah these deepest [ __ ] yeah like
yeah listen to his recent arias his
podcast is fascinating because he he
just likes it yeah he sits there and
gets [ __ ] high with whoever is there
and yeah they have cool compost
spiritual and philosophical and like saw
what does he use a lot of interesting
words like he used to you can't
perpetuate through this I'll kill them
there's a Living Color skit when they
make it funny they're like yeah you
can't put people up on a pedicure if
that [ __ ] prison volcano you I don't
even know if this is using a critter oh
yeah he was also convicted of rape yeah
he talks about [ __ ] fellatio he's
always calling this [ __ ] Felicia wrong
Tyson fat Wow
[Music]